Hi, I'm here with Richard Fulcher.
Richard is a UX Designer at Google.
Senior UX Designer?
>> That's right
>> And has been working on UX for
the last 15 years.
Thank you for joining us, Richard.
>> Oh, it's a pleasure to be here today,
thanks for having me.
>> To get started, can you describe
what user experience design is?
>> Sure, it's a big umbrella
of several related disciplines
that are all focused on
the design of experiences
to help a individual person
achieve some kind of goal.
And that covers a lot of different
types of experiences, most commonly we
think about software design, but it's
also things like environment design, and
maybe the design of physical products.
It can even be things
like event coordination.
It's kind of anything
that a user experiences,
that can be constructed for them.
When I was kind of first taught this,
there was kind of five key concepts.
It's the study of users and
their context,
kind of the environment they operate in,
in order that we can design tools for
them achieve tasks that
let them complete goals.
So users, contexts, tasks.
>> And goals.
>> Goals.
>> Okay, so let's start with the user.
Who are they?
Well, the user is anyone
who's going to use the product of
the service that you're designing.
And it's really important to remember
that, that runs a really wide range.
It's very easy to kind of,
when you're designing,
just think about designing for yourself.
For this one super idealized
user that you have in mind.
But in reality,
you're going to be building this for
people with very different
levels of experience.
With different contexts and
different backgrounds that affect
how they'll perceive this
thing that you built for them.
>> How do I know who the user is?
>> The key for
that is something called user research.
I think it's kind of most
associated with this idea of,
taking this product you're working
on and testing it in some way,
having a user come in and try to perform
a series of tasks that you assign them.
And see how they do and see the things
that are problems for them.
But user research really
covers the whole end-to-end
development of the product.
Even before you've drawn
your first screen,
you can engage with user research to
go into your potential users' homes or
workplaces, to start to understand
that context that's important
to the way that they behave and
what their goals are.
And once you've even kind
of finished and shipped,
you can do things like look at logs and
try to analyze usage patterns,
see what people are doing
with your product.
Perhaps kind of bias towards things
that you want them to do more of, or
see areas that they're spending a lot of
time in that you haven't anticipated.